city leaders in southern China are
denying allegations of coronavirus
racism insisting that foreigners are not
being discriminated against Africans
living in Guangzhou so that they're
being kicked out of their homes and face
harassment as health workers step up
testing to imported infections the
African Union Nigeria and Ghana are
calling on the Chinese government to
address concerns professor Keith rich
Berg is the director of the journalism
and Media Studies Center at the
University of Hong Kong he says there
has been discrimination against Africans
living in China for some time now
ever since she Jinping announced that
the virus was essentially contained in
China and that they could start
reopening businesses and reopening
factories the numbers have been going up
but they've been blaming all of those
new numbers of new cases and the nude up
nude deaths in China on what they call
imported cases meaning that they've
contained it in China but people coming
back into the country are bringing it
along it is it smacks a bit of a sign of
phobia to me because number one most of
these so-called imported cases are
Chinese nationals who left the Chinese
New Year and are just not returning or
returning from schools of rot etc so
these are foreigners these are Chinese
who are bringing in with the virus and
secondly they've been given really no
statistics to prove that the real
numbers of people coming in with the
virus are actually foreigners at all but
you know that's kind of the narrative or
the storyline that they'd like to say is
that all of these new cases are all from
foreigners they've even restricted
foreign diplomats from coming back into
Beijing for example China has always had
this kind of complex relationship with
Africa where as you know no officially
you know that basically the African
countries as brothers that have lately
China has put a lot of development money
into Africa they you know they built the
African Union headquarters they built
the railroad from Kent from Nairobi to
Mombasa
but and and you know and that's a
consequence of these you know tens of
thousands or millions of Chinese living
in Africa you also have a lot of African
traders African students who have gone
over to China and so you know officially
on an official level is this kind of
feeling of fraternity on the ground
level people the people Chinese simply
don't like them very much there there
there
we kind of does a lot of racism I
offended Wong Joe I've been to that area
that they call little Africa or more
derogatory Olivie they call it chocolate
city
the Africans tell me they feel
discriminated against by the Chinese